[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de la grande interview avec cette
semaine jean lassalle le député des
pyrénées atlantiques
tout le monde le connaît c'est un
personnage dans la salle le maire de
lourdios ichère il a été pendant 40 ans
il est député depuis 2002 maintenant
difficile aussi de vous mettre une
étiquette
monsieur le député vous avez fait un peu
de route jadis avec le modem mais depuis
les présidentielles
je suis parle des dernières a pas d
prochaine vous vous êtes mis à votre
compte si je puis dire en créant un
parti résistons résistons c'est
d'ailleurs le titre d'un livre qui est
sorti juste pendant a créé juste après
la au début du mois de juin
donc c'est pas de chance quoi pour vous
ce tarif vous avez écrit avant ça
s'appelle de l'aurore au crépuscule et
ça a été à peine en librairie les
librairies n'était pas encore ouverte
l'esta leaf dans lequel vous dites
j'aime la france vous commencé comme ça
hein vous répondez d'ailleurs à des
lettres de deux de nos compatriotes des
lecteurs de bon vous dites j'aime la
france
mais j'ai peur première question jean
lassalle est ce que la france
d'aujourd'hui avec un premier ministre
qui a un accent aussi fort que le vôtre
qui ne parlent que de territoire et de
régions de départements qui veut
retrouver restaurer cette ce rapport de
proximité entre l'élite et le peuple est
ce que cette france là vous fait moins
peur que celle que vous avez décrite
dans votre bouquin c'est pas tellement
de la france dont j'ai peur c'est de du
sort qui pourrait advenir qui pourrait
être réservé à notre grand et beau pays
qui a marqué l'histoire et qui m'ont
marqué l'humanité par la personnel la
vague a apporté
ça monte à l'humanité bon alors j'ai
c'est de cela dont j'ai peur alors le
cadre de premier ministre ne nous a pas
rassurés parce qu'il dit ce que tous les
premiers ministres ont dit depuis 30 ans
à peu près et malheureusement ce général
et même chimères punissable bonne raison
ce n'est pas mauvais premier ministre je
pense même qu'il est excellent mais il
ya l'argent dans l'espace public de
france je pense y en a pas beaucoup non
plus d'autres pays mais nous n'avons
aucune souveraineté non plus voyez il
faut pouvoir décider je viens de sortir
de la commission de la défense sur deux
divas sont à huis clos mais nous voyons
les dangers qui planent sur le monde et
la france est gelée iter elle veut
devenir veut partout mais n'a plus n'a
pas les moyens il faut retrouver je
crois que comme la plupart des pays nous
devons mener un combat contre le
capitalisme plus exactement ce qui se
sont emparés une fois de plus comme dans
les années 1900 comme dans les années 30
le capitalisme le capitalisme
international avec les résultats que
l'on sait mais j'ai justement quand vous
dites la france de quelle france paraît
vous et et qui accuse et vous de cette
sorte qu'ils portaient qui considérez
vous comme responsable de cette
situation que vous déplorez alors je
pars d'une certaine et des eaux sauvé
les symboles un politique sont très
importants même si c'est pas toujours
une réalité d'une france éternelle c'est
comme ça qu'on a souvent surnommé ce
n'est plus vieux et à aujourd'hui et qui
est ce qu'il aurait mise à cet état là
c'est non c'est à dire les politiques
notamment de ma génération qui avant
étaient totalement à régler
la chute du mur de berlin et
l'effondrement de l'urss
nous étions j'allais pas que un modèle
et nous sommes devenus un système ce qui
est totalement différent système
malheureusement inspiré même si ce n'est
pas une inspiration directement
politique c'est une manière de vivre par
les états unis
donc c'est notre absence vigilance
c'est notre absence de deux visions qui
nous ont conduit dans un peu très
préoccupante situation je vais pas faire
débat et polémique est avec vous c'est
pas mon métier mais on est encore en
core un pays de libertés et notamment de
liberté individuelle est d'ailleurs
cette liberté individuelle est très
protégée par les gens quand on leur
demande par exemple de mettre des
masques aujourd'hui il hésite parce que
c'est une atteinte un peu alors à leur
liberté de mouvement et de mobilité même
si c'est pour protéger le reste de la
population
globalement est un pays de liberté
globalement la gestion de cette crise a
prouvé qu'on avait encore les moyens de
trouver de l'argent pour régler un
certain nombre de problèmes ce peuple 9
cesse de m'étonner
il m'a étonné après charlie hebdo et
mettant à chaque fois que un acte
tragique ça va sûrement quels que soient
les résultats
par contre nous sommes dans une très
grande situation de faiblesse politique
et de faiblesse démocratique
voyez à part votre chaîne qu'il invite
régulièrement toutes les autres chaînes
françaises niña pourtant j'ai fait tous
les plateaux télé et télégramme des
émissions radio g il était présenté par
les plus grands journaux de france mais
aussi quelques heures à l'étranger et le
pays cinq ans à part chez vous et
quelquefois c02 de vos confrères
je ne suis plus nulle pa non la liberté
n'est qu'apparence
en fait nous sommes pris dans un orage
le crâne permanent pour nous faire
admettre une réalité virtuelle et c'est
la raison pour laquelle notre grand
peuple ne vote plus on initie pas la
femme pour ça on n'était jamais descendu
aussi bas
mais quand quand vous parlez vous vous
parlez au nom de vous de vos électeurs
vous parler au nom des agriculteurs
vous parlez au nom des ruraux vous
parler au nom du peuple de plus de
province le peuple de france
vous parlez au nom de qui je parle au
nom de tous ceux dont vaud d'autres se
couvraient le site et je parle au nom
des habitants du 16e arrondissement ou
du 6e au 17e ils ne sont pas les plus
mal tu étais je parle de la france tout
entière
ce que nous ont perdu l'habitude de
faire
nous parlons de l'union européenne
nous parlons de l'otan nous parlant de
la du monde globalisé
qu'est ce que c'est une loi lit qu'est
ce que c'est aimons nos lois 10 mai nous
avions perdu maintenant nous en
reparlons un petit peu de la france
moi j'aime la france et j'aime
l'humanité et je veux contribuer à ce
que la paix qui n'entrait bien le plus
précieux continue à nous accompagner au
moment où tous les dangers s'annonce sur
un ciel chargé
dans je reviens à votre livre dans votre
livre vous faites une liste de tous ses
dangers notamment
vous vous dites à un moment on en a on a
des problèmes de surpopulation on a des
problèmes de gestion de flux quand on
voit tous ces trafics
ces mobilités qui va dans tous les sens
on a des problèmes éventuellement de
d'énergie il ya des pannes d'électricité
vous fait fait la description d'une
panne d'électricité à un moment dans la
ville de détruit c'est une véritable
catastrophe
on a des problèmes parce que on risque
d'avoir des pillards des envahisseurs
tout ça est ce que est ce que ce sont
des problèmes sur lesquels on n'a aucune
prise
aucun moyen ça me paraît quand même être
très technique
ce que vous ce que vous ce que vous
dénoncez je vous comprends très bien
je le regrette de ne pas avoir une plus
forte capacité à vous toucher au caire
et leye aussi votre conscience et en
même temps celle tous ceux qui vous
regardent vous êtes une grande figure de
la presse nationale
mais je vous assure que je ne crains pas
l'humanité je ne crains pas vous avez vu
à dire que des courbes s'affrontent
depuis 48 heures jeux parce que les
cours venant jamais été jusqu'à leur
terme
fort heureusement il y a défait par
exemple la population chinoise devait
être le 2 milliard d'habitants
ils ont accédé à un petit peu de savoir
un petit peu de planning familial et un
enfant par couple vous avez vu que la
population de la chine
le problème n'est pas là le problème
vient du fait que nous ne sommes plus
maîtres de nos vies et c'est devenu un
problème mondial comme les années 30
et c'est les mêmes tireurs de ficelles
qui détiennent capital non pas dans un
souci de bien commun de 20me possible le
progrès et notamment l'intelligence et
le drian artificiel mais dans le sens
d'avoir des profits toujours plus
c'est pour ça qu'ils acceptent au et
compris notre information
mais si on se souvient de ce qu'écrivait
machiavel s'était dit que vous dénoncez
ce totalitarisme mou dont vous parlez un
très souvent il ne peut exister que si
quelque part le peuple la population
profite un petit peu des fruits de 7,2
de ces progrès sinon ils sautent sinon
il explose aussi
oui mais c'est ce que j'explique et je
vous remercie d'avoir lu mon livre avec
l'annotation merci infiniment
mais j'estime qu'un petit peu plus tard
qu'aucune dictature ne résiste à la
classieuse des peuples aucun empire n'a
jamais pu s'imposer durablement par la
face et pas le manque de 2 d'un petit
peu d'égalité et je pense que ceux qui
commencent à se produire
et moi je voudrais que pour une fois
dans l'histoire de l'occident
ça se passe de manière pacifique jean
lassalle
on se retrouve dans une poignée de
secondes pour parler plus précisément de
ce qu'il faudrait faire et notamment du
du programme tel qu'il a été énoncée par
le premier ministre jean charest avant
lui jean castex et puis évidemment de la
crise pandémique dans une poignée de
secondes
[Musique]
bien on se retrouve sur le plateau de la
grande interview avec jean lassalle
député des pyrénées atlantiques jean
lassalle vous voudrez tier-1 diagnostic
de la situation de notre peuple compte
de sa culture compte tenu de son
histoire qui est un diagnostic assez
assez pessimiste est ce que vous
considérez aujourd'hui que ce que nous
venons de vivre
est-ce que nous allons peut-être
continuer de vivre c'est-à-dire cette
épidémie cette pandémie mondiale est un
révélateur de tout ce que vous avez
dit et écrit à l'accélérateur ou une
prise de conscience pour pouvoir saisir
des opportunités de réformes
je veux dire que c'est très exactement
un révélateur et en france c'est la
raison pour laquelle je n'ai rien voulu
changer malgré les appels du pied de mon
éditeur le cherche midi et philippe
héraclès l'érudit pour que je parle du
coc vite j'ai dit non je pense que ce
livre j'écris quatre lignes au départ à
sa cohérence talk et les locaux vite a
été le révélateur de monstres aux pieds
d'argile que nous sommes c'est à dire
nous croyons être devenu intouchable et
en fait nous n'avons plus aucune base et
nous n'avons plus aucune nous ont perdu
tout le savoir faire en matière de vivre
ensemble d'être ensemble d'exister à
sable de se défendre ensemble
donc c'est un révélateur une prise de
conscience une prise de conscience
salutaire
c'est peut-être un mal pour un bien je
m'empêche pas de déplorer nombre de
morts 2 le nombre de ceux qui ont eu
très peur de ce qu'ils auront peut-être
père équivaut en anglais parce qu'on
n'en avons pas fini mais en tout cas une
prise de conscience salutaire parce que
nous avons perdu la raison
oui mais jean lassalle pour la première
fois dans l'histoire on a préféré
protéger des vies humaines plutôt que de
protéger les actifs économique et
l'activité économique
ça va peut-être nous créer d'autres
problèmes mais c'est un fait
oui c'est le premier acte de révolte de
de l'homme et pour parler plus
prosaïquement pour que ce soit pas
technique d'un certain nombre de
gouvernements
et c'est apporter à leur actif
mais c'est encore très timide parce que
les autres ce mensonge dont nous sommes
obligée d'accompagner déjà que la suite
d'un monsieur le premier ministre
pourtant tout neuf et c'est un homme
d'honneur
ce serait se faire et dire après c'est
très difficile mais il a été obligé de
mentir hier après midi nous va venir
l'argent qu'il a promis à profusion dans
prend bien entendu mais qui reste le
maître du jeu de ses enfants
pour l'instant c'est les mêmes et quelle
est notre capacité à nous des femmes
contre le coc vite nous ne le savons pas
encore
contre c'est tout simplement de dénoncer
par le verbe par la prime par la
télévision
l'oeuf silice besogne et qu on se répète
mais l'essentiel sur tétanisé dans les
années 30 comme dans les années 1900 on
va bien avant par leur puissance mots
vides
eh bien nous nous devons aller jusque là
on doit expliquer à nos peurs d'où vient
cette date dans la gestion de la crise
du coc vide
vous considérez que l'état a fait des
erreurs que l'état a menti que l'état
aurait dû gérer autrement qu'il
n'agirait ou pas non c'est pas sur ce
plan-là chemin
je pense que c'est pas qu'ils auraient
pu faire mieux que le président a
maintenant le premier ministre philippe
dans la situation dans laquelle nous
étions non je n'ai pas de critiques
majeures dans sur ce plan-là magnétique
et dans le fait que nos continuant à
nier l'évidence nous sommes en situation
de déni grave à l'égard de nos grands
peuples parce que je n'y vois pas que le
peuple français c'est à dire de
continuer à mentir sur la réalité de
notre pouvoir qui est devenu comme
théâtre dans la réalité de notre pouvoir
c'est vrai elle est souvent beaucoup
plus modeste que selon die en matière de
restauration de l'industrie de
l'appareil économique
on sait très bien on s'en souvient que
vous avez fait une grève de la faim très
spectaculaire pour pouvoir maintenir une
unité industrielle à côté de chez vous
vous avez d'ailleurs gagné quelque part
un mais au prix d'un effort humain et
d'un risque sanitaire important est ce
que c'est la seule solution aujourd'hui
pour obtenir une restauration
industrielle et est ce que la
restauration industrielle de ce type
d'industrie même s'ouvre à la situation
alors j'ai fait je les fais parce que je
n'ai pas trouvé d'autre moyenne ferrand
times
c'est l'époque où la france a perdu 400
mille entreprises par délocalisation par
changement de capitaux enfin tout ce que
vous connaissez mieux que moi
nous ne sommes jamais relevé c'est le
temps aux 6-11 ans perdu définitivement
notre agriculture je ne crois pas pour
répondre très clairement votre question
que ce soit une réindustrialisation
comme ça à qui peut suivre sauver la
france pour savoir qu'est ce qu'on veut
faire c'est une vision tout ça un des
éléments positifs et pendant celle sur
une liste et avant lui le besoin la
république c'est le retour au plan et à
la planification
mais qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière dan
ariely je ne le sais pas moi je pense
qu'il faut se mettre d'accord sur un
nouveau mode d'énergie
je crois que nous sommes beaucoup plus
avancé sur le solaire il faut ne veut
bien le dire
c'est uniquement des intérêts féroce qui
nous maintiennent dans le pétrole est
une source de gags et de de troubles à
l'écologie tragique
nous avons été capables de mettre en
place un projet nucléaire et qui est
discutable l'énergie nucléaire sur
l'ensemble du pays
à moins de 30 ans à l'époque il y avait
30 au sommet de l'état un vrai
visionnaire c'était le général d'euros
nous pouvons faire la même chose pour le
solaire mais bonté divine
au lieu de toujours imploré des niches
ne sais quoi de nous de nous échapper
sur des détails
regardons l'essentiel nous n'avons pas
aujourd'hui l'énergie qui conviennent à
notre ça veut dire ça veut dire ça que
vous êtes à côté des écologistes dans
leur combat pour la protection de
l'environnement et pour le climat
est-ce que c'est véritablement n'ont pas
peut pas faire alors justement expliqué
vous non
est-ce que c'est justement ce que
recherche vos amis agriculteurs par
exemple mais je pense qu'au fond d'eux
mêmes dans leur conscience c'est tous
nos compatriotes qui réclament la même
chose regardez ils ne votent pas mais
maintenant à chaque fois qu'ils votent
ils votent de manière différente et très
très forte surtout si c'était une
poussée des verts donc effectivement
disant cela je réponds moi clairement à
une
la question principale c'est l'avenir de
la planète
c'est l'avenir de notre pays c'est
l'avenir de l'humanité
mais je ne fais pas de la manière que
parce que je ne parle pas là des vrais
militants et militantes du coeur que je
connais dans des parties très avancé je
parle des salopards qui se sont
accaparés de tous et qui ont lassé de
vastes campagnes d'opinion pour
influencer le le citoyen
le peuple pour leur faire peur surtout
de façon à ce que eux comme sa protégée
par tous les moyens d'information puisse
continuer leur sinistre besogne
voyez c'est tout en apparence et au lieu
de la sensibilité
ils ont pris la sensiblerie des gras de
grandes cités qui se sont créés pêle
mêle et avec les banlieues aussi le
socle en connaît jean lassalle vous avez
été proche du gilet jaune
est ce que vous seriez prêt à retourner
avec eux dans la rue si jamais il décide
de retourner dans la rue en septembre
oui bien sûr mais j'étais porsche c'est
de la cgt lorsque organisé
manifestations qui ont été très
contestées
mais nous avons ce pays qui a été le
premier à se lever pour dire je le
peuple est souverain et quelques mois
plus tard dans des tensions terribles
dans des liquidations humaine
on a eu la force d'écrire la déclaration
des droits de l'homme et du citoyen qui
est gravé sur le membre de l'assemblée
nationale et qui a inspiré le monde
entier nous donnons une dimension
universaliste liberté égalité fraternité
laïcité
nous avons perdu tout cela aujourd'hui
c'est la raison pour laquelle je pense
que en plus de la définition d'or de la
grande forme de darchy en plus de la
définition de l'industrie qui a avec de
l'agriculture qui va avec c'est la
culture et de la francophonie de la
langue française dont nous avons besoin
de nous
de nous emparer de nouveau a prénommé
c'est une langue exceptionnel certes
d'apprentissage très difficile mais elle
est porteuse de diversité les porteuses
de d'expérience le liberté de liberté
oui de liberté d'engagement et la
francophonie nous avons laissé tomber
nous ne pouvions pas et à l'heure où les
britanniques
contrairement aux apparences retrouve la
situation millénaire nous avons beaucoup
de retard on veut trouver la nôtre mais
recommencement
vous parlez le même français que jean
castex 1 vous avez quand même 7 ce point
commun c'est à dire que vous vous
entendez vous vous écoutez
1 on sent bien les mêmes sonorités vous
parliez du plan il ya un instant
c'est une idée qui a été reprise par le
président de la république si je ne
m'abuse
on en parle moins la mise en avait parlé
dans son allocution à la télévision avec
même le nom d'un futur haut commissaire
qui est un de vos amis je crois françois
bayrou
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette idée
la coquette hakem de votre question oui
j'ai fait beaucoup de chemin avec
françois bayrou
nous en avons fait contre que pendant
plus de 30 ans et nous avions dépassé le
record de chirac et balladur
mais à partir d'un moment j'ai considéré
que nous parlions mais nous ne disions
plus la même chose et je pense que il ne
faut pas tromper le citoyen électeur en
accréditant lead
une amitié politique qui nappe qui
n'existe plus l'amitié physique louis et
nous la retrouverons parce que nous
avons été trop proche mais l'amitié
politique
non il a fait d'autres choix que les
miens où j'ai fait d'autres choix que
les siens moi je décidé de danser
résolument comme je le fais aujourd'hui
devant votre antenne draps avec votre
interview
la véritable responsabilité du drame qui
se trame aujourd'hui
mais alors ça veut dire 20 noeuds ne se
raconte pas d'histoires en étant
presqu'en rentrer en campagne électorale
en préparation de la campagne
présidentielle
vous serez candidat aux prochaines
présidentielles comme vous l'aviez était
aux précédentes ou pas oui un esterra ne
pas me faire assassiner politiquement
comme celle été lors de la dernière j'ai
fait campagne avec 240 mille euros
lavagne qui a toujours été là bienne a
refusé de me prêter les 800000 euros
auxquels j'avais droit à partir du
moment où j'avais obtenu les 500
signatures alors répondre clairement à
votre question oui connection j'obtienne
aller les signatures mais ce sera très
difficile à obtenir ce aussi parce que
les mercenaires est extrêmement méfiants
ils sont dans la tête de majorité
multicolores
ce qui est très sympa et qui est très
bien pour la gestion d'une commune mais
qui se prête peu à un engagement poèmes
candidat parce que les règles ont été
durcies de cette manière là donc vous
allez reprendre votre tour de france
notre bâton de pèlerin pour aller quêter
ces signatures auprès des nouveaux
maires qui sont certains pour beaucoup
d'ailleurs écologistes même peut-être
profiter du courant que vous défendez
beaucoup d'agriculteurs beaucoup de
petits maires 1
enfin le petit mais voilà mais des
petites communes c'est toujours pareil
nous avons tous les sites et les former
au départ est très rapidement lorsque la
france et ses graffitis fort longtemps
déjà
elle a constaté à la considérait qu'il
fallait à la fois être annaba et l'homme
et le territoire c'est la raison pour
qu'elle nous avons une relation
charnelle entre l'homme et son
territoire et puis progressivement par
facilité par paresse intellectuelle
nous avons considéré qu'il n'y avait
plus que le nombre d'habitants de nous
représenter
si tu ne représentes d'abba 5000
habitants avaient le droit à la parole
mais si je représente bas-côté cent
mille hectares c'est 5000 hectares dont
il faut se défaire non il faut continuer
à aller travailler à les aimer
ah les chérir passionnément parce
qu'elles font partie dans notre pays
au même titre que les 65 millions de
français qui la vivent
jean lassalle merci beaucoup je rappelle
votre votre votre livre aurore au
crépuscule aux éditions du cherche midi
c'est vraiment il faut le dire parce que
je vais vous dire une chose
vous écrivez comme vous parler et ses 7
c'est la sorte cette option
merci beaucoup à bientôt levé je les
ressens pour chaque fois que ça peut te
remercie
merci bonjour tous ces cantonales
écoutez vous reversez on retrouve cette
émission en rediffusion la retrouve en
replay on le retrouve aussi sur le site
internet
rt france point tv et puis nous on se
retrouve très vite
[Musique]